Trascrizione: Silvana Parascandolo
Revisore: Tanja Pengue
Riccardo mi ha chiesto di parlare.
Il tema è "Come funziono".
Quindi stamattina presto mi sono
interrogato su come funziono
ed ho concluso che 18 minuti
sono probabilmente troppi
per raccontare come funziono.
Ci ho ragionato anche poco perché
ero ossessionato dall'idea,
dal concetto di 18 minuti
e non 15 e non 20.
Non riuscivo a capire perché
dovevano essere proprio 18.
E allora mi sono anche ricordato che
il padre di un mio amico,
quando eravamo bambini,
ho preso degli appunti, eh,
non è che ho scritto tutto il discorso.
Il padre del mio amico diceva:
"Tornate alle 10 e 23" o "Alle 7 e 17".
Questo è stato per me,
eravamo molto bambini,
è stato il primo insegnamento
su come si può stare al mondo,
ed è francamente l'unico modo che ho
imparato per stare al mondo.
Cioè di frequentare l'ironia.
Quando quest'uomo diceva:
"Tornate alle 10 e 23",
a suo modo faceva dell'ironia.
Quindi, come funziono.
Provo a funzionare
inseguendo sempre l'ironia, perché
nel mio lavoro, l'ironia costringe
a trovare il ritmo.
Il ritmo è la cosa più,
francamente, rilevante.
Il battito delle cose
è quello che mi serve di più
per provare a fare
dei racconti che abbiano
un interesse e che possano piacere.
Di fatto, il mio modo di procedere
è provare ad essere
costantemente ironico.
Sperando che ogni tanto dentro l'ironia
affiori anche qualcosa di serio.
Da ragazzo ho avuto una parentesi,
invece, in cui
provavo a prendermi molto sul serio
mi resi conto che non veniva fuori niente
e non ho più abbandonato questo tentativo
di frequentare l'ironia.
Va bene.
Le cose che ho concluso stamattina
ragionando su come funziono,
le cose che mi servono,
ho capito che sono svariate,
ma in una specie di ordine,
direi che la prima è la calma.
Riesco a funzionare solo
ed esclusivamente se
lontane da me cose come
l`angoscia e come l`ansia.
Questo, vabbè, è abbastanza scontato.
La seconda cosa che mi fa funzionare
è la frustrazione.
In pratica,
io riesco a elaborare quello che
può essere un futuro film o
un futuro racconto solo se,
sotto sotto,
ho la consapevolezza
di non valere nulla.
Se mi dicono che non valgo nulla,
posso cominciare a cercare di
dimostrare che sono bravo, funziono.
Se mi dicono che sono bravo
cerco di dimostrare che sono
il più bravo di tutti.
Il problema è che col passare
degli anni si diventa realisti
ed è sempre più difficile
credere di essere
i più bravi.
Questo è il problema.
Però la frustrazione è
la vera unica spinta che mi muove.
Trovarmi in quella condizione
in cui ci si trovava da ragazzi,
quando la fidanzata
ti lasciava per un altro,
e tu potevi autoflagellarti.
Quella è la condizione ideale,
secondo me, per creare qualcosa.
Quella di avere costantemente
nella testa una frase che sia:
"Adesso vi faccio vedere io".
Che va di pari passo con
la necessità, secondo me, di sbalordire.
C'è un racconto di Sartre ne "Il muro",
che si chiama Erostrato,
in cui il protagonista dice:
"Voglio sbalordirli tutti".
Almeno quello che mi fa muovere,
è l'idea che ha Flaubert sullo
sbalordimento, quando
dice sostanzialemente che, in un suo libro
spera unicamente in una domanda
dei lettori e la domanda è:
"Ma come ha fatto a fare questo?".
Che posso dire?
Sono passati solamente 9 minuti.
No, mancano 9 minuti e 50.
Io penso di aver già esaurito
le mie motivazioni, no.
Altri elementi
che mi fanno muovere sono
la malinconia.
Che è quella zona,
piuttosto piacevole per certi versi, che
almeno io me la racconto così,
che è un po'
quel momento in cui si riesce
ad essere tristi senza motivo.
Dove da qualche parte si individua
che c'è qualcosa che non va,
ma non si sa cos'è che non va.
Putroppo anche la malinconia è un
sentimento che tende a svanire crescendo.
Almeno a me era una cosa che allignava più
corposamente quando ero ragazzo.
Però ogni tanto riesco
a ritrovarla e a farci qualcosa.
Avere una sensazione
di tristezza per un motivo che non conosci
è un buon movente per mettersi
a creare qualcosa,
perché quel qualcosa che non conosci e che
ti fa essere triste diventa un po'
l'oggetto della ricerca e
uno spera di non trovarlo mai, ovviamente.
Bene.
Un attimo, eh,
poi lo recupero questo silenzio.
Allora,
sì, va bene.
Dovendo parlare del mio lavoro,
sempre da ragazzo, quando feci a scuola,
facemmo la prima lezione di filosofia,
il professore di filosofia entrò e disse:
"Che cosa studia la filosofia?
La filosofia studia tutto."
A me questa cosa mi procurò
un grande brivido.
Invece poi anni dopo,
stando sul divano
e vedendo un film che si chiamava
"Il cielo sopra Berlino",
che rivisto dopo è
un film con delle falle,
ma che visto da ragazzo mi sembrò
un buon motivo per
cominciare a fare il cinema,
mi venne in mente che alla domanda:
"Che cosa può raccontare il cinema?"
si poteva rispondere: "Tutto".
E questo dava effettivamente un brivido.
Dava una capacità di emozionarsi.
La capacità di emozionarsi
dovrebbe essere anche
un altro buon elemento da utilizzare per
funzionare, sebbene a mio parere,
è ancora più importante la capacità
che ciascuno dovrebbe avere,
di non emozionarsi,
per fare un lavoro artistico.
Invece, spesso si rimane
un po' vittime di questa
trappola, che ci si emoziona molto,
si finisce per emozionarsi di sè stessi
e forse posso azzardare
che emozionandosi di sè stessi
si finisce per essere retorici. Ecco.
Quello che proprio penso vada evitato
a tutti i costi, che è il male assoluto
di un lavoro che abbia a che fare
con la creazione di mondi paralleli
è proprio la retorica.
Che invece è forse quello
che è più presente in assoluto
nelle cose che non ci piacciono
o quanto meno, che non mi piacciono.
Quindi, per cercare
di avere la capacità di emozionarsi,
ma allo stesso tempo avere la capacità
di non emozionarsi troppo,
il mio tentativo molto spesso
è quello di essere neutro.
O di essere neutrale.
Neutro mi consente di fare quello che
di fare quello che più mi piace fare
e che più mi serve per il lavoro,
che vuol dire che è osservare. Insomma,
secondo un luogo comune vero,
nel tipo di lavoro che faccio io,
si è a buon punto quando,
entrando in un ristorante,
non si parla con la persona che
sta seduta al tavolo con te
ma si osservano quelli
che stanno agli altri tavoli.
E questo è
uno degli elementi decisivi,
almeno per me, per funzionare.
Non so se sono noioso, sicuramente sì,
perché adesso, tra l'altro,
volevo parlare proprio della noia,
che per osservare bisogna avere
una grande capacità di annoiarsi,
almeno per me.
E per creare delle cose buone, ritengo che
si riescono a creare delle cose buone
man mano che la noia aumenta.
La cosa migliore
è essere allenati da bambini
a diventare noiosi. Io faccio
ancora parte di una generazione
per cui i genitori erano
sufficientemente disinteressati
a noi da lasciarci annoiare.
Purtroppo questa
bella caratteristica sta un po' svanendo.
I genitori di oggi
tendono a evitare in tutti i modi
di far annoiare i bambini. Dopo la scuola
li portano a fare altre attività
e quando finisce la scuola,
li portano a una cosa che oggi
si chiama campo scuola.
Almeno dove abito io.
Coprono un po' tutti i buchi che
che sono relativi alla noia,
mentre invece la noia è esattamente
la piattaforma necessaria
per cominciare creare
dei mondi paralleli.
Solo annoiandosi del mondo
si ha la possibilità di creare
un proprio mondo e creare un proprio mondo
forse è la massima priorità
per scrivere un racconto,
per scrivere un film
o per fare una canzone o
un quadro.
Mentre sono convinto
che dato che il mio lavoro vive
anche di dialoghi che
se riesco a creare dei buoni dialoghi,
questi nascono
esclusivamente dal fatto che
nella vita vera le conversazioni
con le persone sono molto spesso noiose,
perché sono improntate
a una specie di diktat che può protrarsi
alle volte per tempi infiniti,
che è quello del
parlare del più e del meno.
La noia delle conversazioni nella
vita vera mi spingono a cercare
dei dialoghi che non raccontino
del più e del meno.
Un'altra cosa che ci tenevo a dire è che
uno dei più grossi attentati
alla noia dei bambini odierni
è dato dal fatto che
i Big Jim sono stati messi
fuori produzione.
Io l'ho scoperto di recente,
non sono più in produzione.
Sono in produzione solo le Barbie,
ma non più i Big Jim.
Quindi ci sono buone possibilità
che col tempo
artisti diventino
solo ed esclusivamente le donne,
perché i Big Jim nella mia infanzia
erano il primo grande
campo di allenamento
per raccontare le storie,
perché erano
il punto preciso di contatto fra
la realtà, perché erano molto reali,
e allo stesso tempo
non erano reali perché erano
di plastica insomma.
Ritornando a quello che mi sta a cuore,
che è l'osservazione, volevo dire che,
per osservazione io intendo
esclusivamente il momento
in cui un individuo
fa un passo falso, è l'unica cosa che mi
serve per raccontare qualcosa.
L'unico elemento che trovo davvero attraente
nell'osservazione degli individui
è la distanza che esiste fra
l'immagine che gli uomini
vogliono dare di sè e quel momento
in cui attraverso sempre
esclusivamente un dettaglio,
mai qualcosa di enorme ma attraverso
un piccolo dettaglio,
tradiscono loro stessi
e fanno uscire fuori qualcosa che
non gli appartiene,
che rivela una verità altra.
E quindi per attendere l'avvento
di questo dettaglio, spesso
mi tocca osservare
per un tempo molto lungo.
È il motivo per cui poi
al ristorante le persone,
se ci vado una volta, tendono a non
venire con me una seconda volta perché
osservo per tutta la durata del pranzo
o della cena gli altri tavoli.
Ah ecco.
Dunque, un altro elemento
che mi sembra decisivo
nel mio lavoro, è che
attraverso la noia e quindi attraverso
la noia del mondo e attraverso
la possibilità di creare un mio mondo
e di creare un mio sistema di proprità
questo deve per forza coincidere con
un imperativo categorico per me
che è quello di essere un dilettante.
Trovo che il buon cinema sia
il regno dei dilettanti
e anzi a dire la verità,
ho scelto di fare il cinema proprio perché
Per statuto il cinema è
il luogo dove i dilettanti
possono trovare una loro collocazione.
(SUONA UN ALLARME)
Sono lieto di apprendere che
è finito il tempo.
Va bene, allora un attimo solo,
volevo dire un'ultima cosa.
- Scusa, fregatene! Ok...
- Ho ancora un minuto?
- Sì, anche due.
Sì, perché adesso c'era il capitolo
"Come funziono",
ma mi rendo conto che è finito il tempo.
Ho due minuti per dire come funziono.
Allora, se mi fanno sentire
solo e abbandonato,
comincio a funzionare,
comincio ad accumulare materiale.
E poi faccio la cosa
che è più difficile per questo lavoro,
vale a dire, comincio a fare le rime.
Non so esattamente spiegare che cosa
sono le rime al cinema, ma vuol dire
mettere insieme, collegare cose.
Anche qui aiuta il tipo di gioco
che uno è in grado di fare.
Tutti coloro che facevano
o fanno o provano a fare giochi,
per cui associano le cose,
sono a buon punto,
secondo me, su questo lavoro.
E quindi semplicemente questo.
Va bene, volevo parlare della musica
e di come si può creare utilizzando
la musica, ma il tempo stringe.
Tenete conto che sono anche il primo
che fa questa cosa in Italia,
e quindi se siete rimasti...
(APPLAUSI)
Se siete rimasti delusi...
Dico due ultimissime cose
perché magari c'è sempre
chi vuole intraprendere
questo lavoro.
Mi piace sempre dare dei consigli.
Per chi vuole fare un film o scrivere
un libro, più scrivere film che libri
perché faccio quello.
Ed è questo: di vedere molti film brutti
e prima di mettersi a scrivere una storia,
di leggere sempre il Guinnes dei primati
che è quel libro, nel quale
c'è la più grande concentrazione
di cose eccezionali che sono anche reali.
Questo dovrebbe essere il cinema:
Eccezionale nel Reale.
Ho finito.
Grazie.